ça va exiger de ce 69 euros ce chiffre
exact nous sommes en train de le
développer dans nous aurions quelque
chose à dire pour avoir des anneaux
2 restants engagés de façon humanitaire
sur les réfugiés mais aussi avec ses
forces armées
contre la chaux débat on le disait le
premier ministre trudeau sera de retour
au pays demain son départ a coïncidé
souvenez vous avec les terribles
attentats à paris un gros test pour un
gouvernement qui vient tout juste
d'arriver au pouvoir
alors justin trudeau at il été à la
hauteur de ces moments difficiles
j'en parle avec michel et daniel qui
sont ici avec moi et tasha qui est à
ottawa ce soit avant soit ou trois
contents vous soyez là daniel content
aussi
alors commençons par la forme si vous le
voulez bien parce que c'est quand même
on l'a vu des images assez saisissante
quand même de lui acclamé comme une
rock-star beaucoup de celles fille
d'autoportraits comment est-ce que vous
évaluer sa performance achat d'un côté
on peut pas on peut payer pour de
meilleures publicités les filles qui
crie après lui comme un boxeur écoute
c'est pas inventé c'est là c'est la
réaction humaine à sa présence alors ça
sert à rien à le critiquer je pense que
monsieur trudeau a été très et c'est une
réussite des coûte son début sur la
sellette nationale il était avec un très
bon je pense un acte du chaleureux comme
il est d'habitude envers les autres cher
et ça se montre par un bon début de
relation c'est ce qu'on voudrait pour le
canada maintenant c'est vraiment
l'action qui va prendre qui va décider
si ça continue michel vont beaucoup de
vedettariat enfin lyon qu'est-ce que ça
ça peut nuire à sa crédibilité
bah écoutez moi quand j'ai vu monsieur
trudeau réagir aux attentats de paris et
c'est un peu impressionnant il bafouille
est il y avait l'impression de pas trop
savoir si c'est le vendredi soir c'était
tout un contraste avec le président
allende
ça a été tout un contraste avec monsieur
obama on avait l'impression que tu nous
avais pas vraiment senti la dimension du
drame qui se déroulait et à partir de ce
moment là je comprends qu'à l'extérieur
c'est une rock star mais vous savez à
man et les philippins ont pas s'occuper
de savoir s'il va être un bon premier
ministre
pas un bon premier ministre ocana donne
nous c'est le premier ministre qui
faisait ses premiers pas je comprends
que le baptême du feu était sérieux mais
on avait eu l'impression pendant la
campagne électorale que le torino ou du
temps qu'on avait vu avant cette chose
du passé puisque maintenant que les
vraies affaires commencer il serait à la
hauteur mais ce qu'on a vu là ça
semblait beaucoup plus haut trudeau à
mon sens d'avant la campagne électorale
et posez vous les beaucoup de gens se
sont posé la question si tout ça était
arrivé un mois plus tôt à ce que ça on
aurait eu les mêmes résultats l'été à
l'élection de 19 ou plus joueurs
n'ont-ils pas eu d'erreur mais au plus
encore que dit michel cette arrivée au
canada comment il avait réagi à ce qu'il
aurait été capable de rassurer les
canadiens
il aurait dit quoi il aurait fait quoi
rappelez vous quand c'est arrivé aux
états unis en septembre 2001 comment
george bush d complètement débalancé il
ya des questions à se poser de ce que
tout cela donne la chance au coureur
mois sur sur les égos pas très bon 15 à
la blague aujourd'hui les philippines en
principe c'est justin bieber mais je
pense qu'ils l'ont quillan probablement
vraiment reconnu mais cette je comprends
qu'il est en phase avec son époque des
esgaulx portrait ça fait partie de la
vie de cette génération
les gens qui veulent prendre mais ici
prête avec un plaisir énorme et ça donne
parfois l'impression surtout ce jour
dernier après paris ça donne l espèce
d'impression de légèreté et ça c'est
agaçant et rappelez vous quand le
président obama avait fait ce fameux et
aux groupes égaux par train avec la
première ministre du danemark comme on
l'avait critiqué à l'afrique sa cette
manie très sérieuse nelson mandela et
voilà précisant qu'ils s'amusent à faire
des esgaulx parfait c'est il faut je
comprends qu'ils le fassent
qu'ils continuent à nous femmes fonction
soit très bien dosé parce qu'à un moment
donné alors parlons ça c'est oui c'est
léger c'est la forme parlons du fond
maintenant
commençons avec 2
le retrait des cf 18 canadiens parce que
monsieur trudeau maintien cela comme si
les attentats de paris n'était pas
arrivée michel est ce qu'on n'est pas
contre quoi on est on est à
contre-courant complètement elle a
écouté tout le monde se promet de faire
un effort additionnel et nous on diminue
notre notre contribution
je comprends que les frappes canadienne
sait peu de choses là où de façon
objective
mais ça donne l'impression qu'on veut
pas vraiment aller se battre alors que
je pense que l'opinion canadienne à
mieux c est peut-être que monsieur
trudeau là ce qui s'est passé à paris
on n'est pas là c'est pas la guerre en
irak lé saddam hussein était un terrible
boucher mais n'exportait pas être cités
là on est face à des gens qui ont
déclaré la guerre à peu près à tout
l'occident et ça je pense que le geste
de monsieur trudeau donne l'impression
qu'il n'a pas compris et michel raison
la participation du canadien du canada
aux frappes aériennes ces séminaires
mais c'est symbolique et c'est un
symbole important mais justin trudeau
veut tellement se démarquer de la proche
guerrière qui était celle de stephen
harper qu'il oublie tout le reste
oui faire de la formation oui
participent à l'entraînement ses
geôliers c ku mais ils savent assemble
aussi un peu à de l'angélisme
il ya un rôle important joué le canal
est au pays du g7 sépare pays sous
développés sous développés ou émergents
ce ton pays du g7 qui joue avec des
grands sur le plan économique tend
toutes les grandes décisions
il faut aussi que sur le plan militaire
tu joues avec les grands ici ça implique
de faire des frappes aériennes
tu fais des frappes aériennes c'est
quand même une promesse tient à tenir
cette promesse d'achat on reproche
souvent aux politiciens ne pas le faire
sk pas une contradiction là bah écoutez
moi j'attends qu'il garde sa promesse
sur le déficit de 10 milliards de
dollars je suis je te jure je jure est
ici ce soir que sera est plus grand que
ce temps il va briser celle là ça va
être 14 ou 15 milliards de dollars en
est un mais deux sur celle ci dès demain
avec le ministre des finances fait une
mise à jour économique
exactement on va voir on peut-être on va
savoir demain c'est vrai mais écoutez je
pense que sur la promesse ici moi
j'étais déçu dans le sens que quand j'ai
regardé monsieur hollande livrer son
discours à versailles c'était est clair
c'est émouvant ce que la demande aux
alliés d'être avec la france le canada
et depuis très longtemps effectivement
un fort allié de la france et de
l'europe en général et c'était un moment
je pense monsieur trudeau aurait bien pu
dire écoutez je je je je vais écouter
cette demande là il a ou tololo faire ça
il a parlé une heure avant le discours
de monsieur hollande n'a pas attendu
cela pour faire la déclaration qui va
pas envoyer des bombes affaires de
bombardements et ça ça m'a déçu parce
que je pensais c'était une occasion
monsieur trudeau aurait pu légitimement
dire on va continuer pour une période de
temps pour soutenir nos alliés et les
canadiens je serai dans sera construit
mais approuvé au canada participe aux
bombardements moins bons sont les
réfugiés parce qu'il ya aussi toute
cette question des réfugiés qui qui
continue de tout le monde est un peu
dans le flou encore sur ce qu'elle va
faire
mais il maintient cette promesse là
aussi alors là aussi à un manque de
sensibilité
ouais enfin moi je qualifierais de
manque de sensibilité accueillir vingt
cinq mille réfugiés le canada pour le
faire il ya aucun doute là dessus j'en
suis les accueillir avant le 1er janvier
c'est utopique c'est désespéré c'est
beaucoup trop vite on risque de créer le
chaos d'avoir des situations intenables
et de compromettre la suite des choses
donc là dessus là où justin trudeau fait
une erreur c'est un en ne disant pas
rapidement écoutez c'est pas c'est pas
si loin possible avant le 1er janvier
on va le faire sur une période puis
lâche deuxièmement loup il fait une
erreur à mon avis ces deux pour
percevoir la sensibilité des gens encore
aujourd'hui manuel base premier ministre
france disait il ya probablement des
terroristes qui ont profité de la crise
des réfugiés pour s'infiltrer en france
c'est rien pour rassurer les gens qui
ont décrété des craintes légitimes et
c'est le rôle d'un chef de gouvernement
le pays comme le canada de dire je
comprends vous êtes inquiet des sondages
démontrent que presque 60 % des
canadiens sont inquiets
vous écoute on va prendre notre temps
mais mon objectif reste le même cela dit
on dit que ce ne sont pas les réfugiés
qu'on voit arriver massivement en europe
qui se sont des réfugiés qui sont déjà
descendus aujourd'hui et c'est donc déjà
une sélection
oui mais oui mais encore là on est on
est pas à une époque antérieure monsieur
trudeau se trompe de guerre je peux dire
de la même façon ils se trompent de
réfugiés la cible plus les boat people
c'est pas les consommer là on est dans
un contexte et avec une population qui
fait peur qu'on le veuille ou non il ya
de l'islamophobie qui qui qui tient
largement à la peur et on rassure pas
les gens en les bousculant et quand même
un maire comme maire de québec vient
vous dire moi je repars des dégâts
nerveux de il fait peur au monde
autrement dit les gens qu'on va
accueillir cette tête des terroristes en
puissance alors partir de ce moment là
il faut vraiment y aller avec beaucoup
de doigté et la dernière chose à faire
c'est effectivement donner l'impression
aux gens qu'on doit se passer n'importe
qui et c'est ce qu'a eu un manque de
pédagogie un manque d'explications de
communication de la part du gouvernement
bah oui aussi on n'a pas de détails on
ne sait pas le coup les provinces les
villes ne savent pas qui va assumer le
coût au cas du québec
on demande maintenant 2002 réfugiés de
plus qui sont admis est ce que est ce
que c'est ottawa qui le paie pour ça on
ne sait pas mais je pense que c'est sûr
aussi c'est très sensible et la
population c'est dangereux je pense
aussi de dire que on va simplement
continuer noir et blanc on va faire ça
d'ici le 1er janvier
parce que ça risque aussi de provoquer
des situations de où les gens se sentent
on peut on perd comme on a dit et que
peut-être des incidents comme le mexique
et à peterborough on veut pas répéter ça
on veut que le population qu'elle a
devant lui un assentiment gimone qui a
été attaquée dans l'est absolument on
veut pas de crime de haine on veut pas
que se seraient produits il faut que les
gens c'est que ce soit rassuré que cette
situation de réfugiés s'est pris au
sérieux et monsieur trudeau a fait la
promesse en mai il a fait la promesse en
mai 2015 six mois avant la fin de
l'année pourquoi il peut pas simplement
dire on prend six mois au lieu de six
semaines perso
un nid critiquerez là-dessus admettent
les réfugiés c'est une bonne chose mais
faites-le d'une façon organisée et
secure alors si je vous entends bien il
est temps qu'ils reviennent au pays
peut-être pour commencer à s'occuper des
gens qui reviennent au pays mais il doit
partir quoi banque après une première
rencontre le giro 10e grattait ça va
être les élèves du premier ministre
avait aussi un laboratoire sa seat
schuman pour n'en nommer qu'un seul qui
ait enlevé avec les maires du du clip du
québec et du canada qui ont de sérieuses
inquiétudes des jeux centre d'où va
devoir s'expliquer clairement il va
devoir être convaincant il va devoir
savoir où il va
le plan de d'accueil dont on nous parle
depuis chapeau une éternité
il va falloir à un moment donné qu'on
voit ce plan là s'il existe vraiment
aussi les prêts donc le jeudi prochain
c'est un très gros test pour lui mais on
répare et d'environnement là on peut
reprendre pas évident non je pense qu'on
va en parler la conférence de paris va
avoir lieu quand même mais je pense que
les gens vont dire à monsieur trudeau et
monsieur couillard a été extrêmement
différents pas voulu le contredire
publiquement mais on a tous compris que
ça n'a pas de bon sens que le québec
pourrait pas vivre et ça je pense que là
on va l'expliquer clairement mais
surtout des ministres qui l'ont dit
assez clairement
ou alors ta chance sur la toile on dit
merci beaucoup merci à vous deux
poursuivra tous à la semaine prochaine